when was the last time that a republican
majority
passed a piece of legislation at the
federal level
that benefited the lives of average
working-class Americans
can you think of a single specific
instance
where they did something like that we
have seen them bust up unions which has
hurt the middle class
we have seen them ignore environmental
pollution and destruction which is
harming low-income and middle-income
American people they live in areas that
are you know tend to be statistically
far more polluted than where the one
percent lives
they have done nothing to make your life
better
they've done plenty to make it worse